The answer is less than 0.05. Here's how we know that. Remember, we did a 5%
test. Alpha equals 0.05. That means that this area beyond here. Is 5% of the
distribution. Remember, the critical value cuts off the lower 5% of the
distribution. The p value is this area, right here, cut off by our value of t.
So remember, a p value is just a proportion of scores that fall beyond a score.
So in this case, the one-tailed p value has to smaller than 0.5, because this
small chunk here is smaller than this chunk right here. So, p has to be less
than 0.5. Now again, when we're doing these by hand, we don't know the exact p
value But we can use a calculator to look it up. I'll do that right now for
you. The exact one tailed p value is 0.00985. You can clearly see that this is
much less than 0.05. So p is less than 0.05. We would probably present this p
value if we were writing this out in the result section. As p is equal to 0.01.
That's because we round to two decimal places.